من رام الله ممارسه الجزيره سمير ابو
شماله سمير كيف تتعامل اسرائيل مع هذه
الهجمات والصديقات والاستلاءات على
قواعدها
يعني بدايه كان في هذا الموضوع جلال
النيابه والشرطه العسكريه
وايضا القوات جهاز الامن العام الشباب هي
تخوت هذه المعركه في التحقيق والباحث
والتحري عن طبيعه اقتحام هذا الموقع
ومواقع اخرى خلال اسابيع ماضيه وهذا يصور
الجيش واجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه بخوف
كبيره بان تصل هذه الذائر الى همم
الفصائل وتنظيمات الفلسطينيه وايضا تعرض
من جنود ومواطنه همم الاسرائيليين في داخل
الضفه الغربيه الخطر ما حدث الليله الماضي
وتحديدا في الموقع الصنوبر وهو موقع تدريب
عسكري يتابع لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
الجولان السوري المحتل قد تم اختراق
واقتحام هذا الموقع وايضا سرقه يقارب حسب
بيان جيش الاحتلال ووسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه باكثر من 70,000 همم رصاصه او
عيار ناري وايضا 7000 عبوه شديده الانفجار
من داخل هدف
الموقع وكان قد تم اكتشاف هذا هذه السرقه
عندما كان هناك جرد ليلي في مستودعات
ومخابئ هذا الموقع الخاص بتدريب الجيش
الايسر في هضبه الجولان السوري المحتل هذا
الاجهزه الامن والجهاز الامن العام للشباب
والشرطه العسكريه بدات بالتحقيق وما زال
هذا التحقيق بجارا وايضا كان هناك عمليات
تحقيق جاريه في هذا الموضوع من خلال تتبع
لهذه الجهه المنفذه لعمليه السرقه وكان
هناك اعتقال قبل ثلاثه اسابيع
لثلاثه اشخاص حسب ذكرته وسائل الاعلام
اشتبهت به من القوات الايطاليه بينهم
كانوا يحاولون اختراق واقتحام معسكر خاصه
للتدريب في تلك المنطقه وتم اعتقال اثنين
ايضا شكرا المجموعه
محيط هذا المعسكر هذا هذه الطريقه ايضا
كان هناك قبل
كان هناك اقتحام بموقع الواجب عاتي في
جنوب اسرائيل وتحديدا في النقب وايضا سرقه
ما يقرب من 30,000 عيار النبي في ذلك
الموقع شكرا في رام الله